salut tout le monde bon la sortie de
petits chapeaux pour penser de vidéos
parce que philippe bach démarrent la
partie cette fois ci avec une tour de
moi donc d'une costauds quoi je veux
qu'une tombe et il affronte quelqu'un
qui s'appelle monsieur coderre côté eco
terre je sais pas combien il va c'est
parti là bas ils envoient aux quatre
boutons et f4 donc bah un tour en plus
tour en moins un peu importe il envoie
gambie roi est aspiré ses principes de
voir à la possession du centre les noirs
contre attaque le centre par des cinq
pas mal et il fait qu'ils avaient ri et
rend alors à noter qu'ici une faute
serait de prendre même chose à une tour
ici ça marche pas non plus il ya damage
quatre échecs
ici on fait j'ai 3 il ya dan franck
eurent attaqué à tour donc gagner encore
d'autres moi ça serait lourd ouais donc
il fait qu'à liège trois prises
j'en prends et la moelle et noir
prennent une mauvaise route même s'il
n'ya rien de mal pour l'instant il a
repris le pion mais franchement le plus
logique
franchement il faut se développer
faucheux kalyev si ce projet qualifient
ce pourquoi pas vous reprendre avec le
client des 5 et vidic sur la dame qui
perdent des tempos et 2 2 même si on
reprend bastion si vite
on fait juste flo7 petit on oublie
pendant une porte plus et voilà on cache
le roi ont fait sauter deux cents petit
à petit puis on va la gagner cette
partie quoi mais va me prend on semble
que les noirs fils fils nourrit coton
cassé trois côtes développement gain de
temps khaddam défense puis mon passage
anecdotique dames 6 échecs baroque de
brefs de pas m on pourra faire photo
mais en fait en f2 il est pas si mal
parce que maintenant quand on bouge le
fou on va mais c'est heureux enfilade de
2 pouces et 5 et ben c'est pas grave
parce qu'on fait des quatre donc couple
échec et défendra alors wife deux belles
chaussettes et bas des quatre voilà
prendre centre mais non on fait cap 6 il
récupère déjà ce petit pion et il ya eu
qui avait eu quatre échecs mange mange
pour penser ça
bon alors jusqu'à présent on va dire que
les noirs ici si mal joué
ça va il a tour à tour de plus il ya que
perdre une option dans la bagarre
mais il faudrait penser au développement
on ne dira jamais c'est remet un couche
au maroc quand même logique
qu'est ce qui fait qu'elle sait si ce
bon c'est caraco développement mais on
sait qu'il aura cette pièce importante
fou des trois dames de six tours avec
tempo dame prend à deux voies la dame
par un peu loin mais c'est pas trop la
lie à foug b5 décision intéressante des
blancs et cinq passes conclut le
cavalier on veut faire des 5
et ça c'est bien jouer il faut 17 et il
fait des cinq quand même et là
maintenant avec les noirs même ça peut
faire un exercice si vous voulez de
mettre une fois sur pause comment vous
auriez donc vous avez une tortue russe
mais les blancs constituent sciatique
alors quoi faire dans la partie il a
joué ça donne trempions est trop
gourmand il prend trop de choses et
c'est vraiment une faute la meilleure
solution
c'était décidé de rendre du matériel
sainte où il faut toujours faire coudre
et du matériel en plus c'est d'en rendre
puisque
vous écrire un steak quelque chose et
l'apparent croquer ces tests et bonne
idée parce que sur qui on prend ces 6000
objets de reprendre les pertes se fout
vous avez quand même ce coup de pouce et
5 intermédiaire échec
dis donc le roi s'en aille ans et angers
3 maintenant fou prend part en prend par
exemple
et si on fait le compte on a quand même
une qualité plus akhenaton quand
cavalier est un pion
j'ai quand même bien suffisant pas et
ouais et donc là c'est là qu'il fait la
faute
il y fait d'offre en b2 et qu'ils ont du
coup ils encaissaient deux pièces avec
les noëls reproduction est ici un
nouveau moment important je vous laisse
réfléchir comment continuer à attaquer
avec les mains ça c'est bien si vous
avez le temps mettez sur pause refuge
c'est par le même essayer de voir les
variantes les mieux possible qu'elle
pourrait éventuellement les défenses
tout ça mais alors pour les vaillons
qu'on cherche et on continue fou prend
6,6 très bien joué donc on attaque suis
là bas ils prennent tout reprend le 7 en
trois sets alors à noter que si les
noirs ne prennent pas effondré fuite
on va faire date des six on attaque le
flou et surtout une semaine découverte
et à dame pensait de bien sûr mauvais
puisque on ramène la tour donc on
protège de l'échec
nouvel échec nous mêmes au renoir et on
va encaisser la dame au prochain coup de
votre tour qui n'ont pas d'âme france et
2 et donc sont un peu comme moi j'ai été
vite en les découvertes il ya dame prend
attaque la tour even asmat du couloir
donc ça serait gagnant pour les blancs à
leur tour procès de l'affairé prend ya
eu dam des six ont reçu huit dames
français 6 échecs recettes food et six
bien joué donc si vous avez fait
l'exercice j'espère vous avez vu tout ça
passer et c'était bien là rivard son
parti ici à noter que simon et droit on
peut par exemple faire simplement fou à
trois échecs à la découverte ont manqué
cela dames et en plus le roi et
dans de sales draps sûrement que maria
mater très vite il a fait roi des 8es il
ya eu dames c'est cet échec aura rouge
et mat en 1 27
voilà de belles parties d'attac surtout
donc à partir de là le label combine
foot français 6 des villes foule à tord
prend le sac pour faire d'un v6 le fou
qui va être en l'air le roi qui est
maintenu ça c'est une belle phase de jeu
et voilà buck j'espère que ça vous a plu
et et puis je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao ciao